tout d'abord je dois dire que moi je
pensais playback
moi je plaît ou ne plaît pas et pis
c'est tout et aux échos m'a dit michel
briquet dans notre émission vous pouvez
prendre tous les risques
les choisit c'est quand même la sécurité
alors je me mouille pas je choisis la
sécurité qu'est ce qui me gêne aussi les
clés de ma loge s'appelle saad et les
dunes aussi une borne kilométrique
à défaut donc dernièrement j'ai vu une
émission à la télévision qui m'a
beaucoup intéressé c'était l'année
dernière
sir la vie des mozart et ça m'a donné
l'envi des lire sa biographie
c'est comme ça que je me suis aperçu que
nous avons des points communs avec
mozart par exemple consomme biologiste
écrit kelly moore est rare chez les
génies ma modestie m'oblige à penser que
je n'ai donc pas d'humour
ou alors que les suis un des rares à
avoir les deux et comme il l'écrit
kébreau arabes et les deux c'est un
premier point commun
deuxième point commun à quatre ans
mozart composaient son premier livre est
et moi aussi à 4 ans j'ouvrais mon
premier livre est à la caisse d'epargne
troisième point commun avec moïse avec
mozart et parce qu'avec moi aussi je les
points communs
quand il est monté sur le mont sinaï a
mené 3000 avant jc
pour aller chercher les dix
commandements il est resté là au 40
jours après le dixième - justement c'est
tout et l'éternel répond prend déjà ça
si ça se vende bien j'en écrirai
d'autres mais la différence avec moïse
c'était lui réserver la parole divine
il avait quatre ans m tandis que moi
j'écris la parole l epitech pas divine
mais divine et combien ils gagnent à
être connus
donc troisième point commun avec mozart
mozart à 25 ans était au sommet de son
génie et c'est là que nos chemins
divergent
parce que moi à 25 ans je dois
reconnaître que la source volcanique qui
demandait sous lé sommet des mâts
calotte crânienne ne trouvait pas la
sortie
j'ai reconnaît humblement que je suis
resté longtemps en bouche et je trouvais
pas le débouché
et un jour ou plutôt une nuit comme
beethoven et il entendit pompon peau
j'ai entendu popeck je me suis dit c'est
un signe et j'ai ouvert les yeux et
c'est là que je les appelais xi j'ai vu
la vierge comme j'aime boire je me suis
dit c'est pas possible c'est trompé
d'appartement vous fait ça m'arrive
c'est pour ça qu'il n'ait jamais dit à
personne je savais qu'on me croirait pas
et il m'a parlé elle m'a dit popeck le
monde est triste c'est moi rire il lui
dit avec quoi señorita moi c'est la mère
du seigneur bon à l'enseigné rita
et elle m'a tendu un stylo un diplôme
hors garantie 3 ans elle m'a dit écrit
et la disparue sans jamais réparé et
pourtant je les appelais plusieurs fois
mais il faudrait des riches pour les
stylos et à l'eau dernier point avec coo
et mozart qui a écrit une sonate en
aluminium en élite et mimi nerfs
intitulé les marchés aux tirs et moi
parallèlement sa musique j'ai gris in
sauna temps d'un poème embraque 1 dit il
et les marchés aux tic
si vous voulez je peux vous enchanter un
morceau et m'aurait fallu un pianiste
pour m'accompagner montfrin vous savez
j'ai demandé au conservatoire j'ai
demandé un bon pianiste ils m'ont
proposé un premier prix alors je les
vire au dernier prix c'est combien celle
des prix inquiète ne savais rien je vais
chanter tout seul je vais vous chanter
la vie des marchés
mon ami le vieux machos des caleçons
molletonnés qui y va de ville en village
s'il a passé des marchés près de lui il
ya les bouquinistes et la mercière
et vos bouchées et la jolie petite
clovis et à l'accent des méditerranée et
je vois encore ces bâtiments mal à
monter et à démonter à des vallées
savoie comines et crécelles et bouffant
des pellicules approché tout chez moi ce
n'est pas de la gnognotte et à faucher
choisissez cgc la doter c'est quand il
fait froid qu'on se sent bien dans les
tic et la fille ne lui vous piquez pas
les kits cetera et cetera
vialade riquet où les jolies piano c'est
pour moi que vous l'avez celui là olala
des touches sont toutes noires dit dont
il a besoin d'aller chez le dentiste
oui je préfère un détartrage que ça me
donne une idée si j'ai encore une minute
géant boeing
je vais vous jouez là je vais vous la
jouer à les marchés aux tic à l'aris
seulement je dois vous prévenir que si
vous entendez des fausses notes ne les
croyez pas inséré de la propagande anti
soviétique
je vous demande juste une minute les
temps de faire la mise au point avec mes
musiciens
alors écoutez moi bien vous êtes dix
doigts il ya 85 note y en aura pour tout
le monde
alors ne vous montez par les anciens les
autres
comment s'est allégé tôt et finissait
très tôt et c'est là que vous allez voir
que nos points communs serré joint avec
mozart parce que si c'est vrai que la
musique adoucit les moeurs les tissus
aussi adoucir les makes parce que mozart
vous réchauffe l'homme par la musique
mais moi j'ai vous réchauffe les types
variés dans le temps
non